hi friends its Anka I recently heard
about this place called the dream
machine it calls itself a new immersive
experience that brings the most magical
dreams to life we're supposed to walk
through ten rooms that are inspired by
our sleep cycle I have absolutely no
idea what that means but we're just
gonna go to the location check it out
and have some fun
I'm Paige Solomon I'm the co-founder and
creative director of dream machine dream
machine was inspired by sleep dreams and
the whimsical nature of dreaming we
wanted to create a space that was a
respite from reality you'll find
yourself walking through a cloud land on
cloud 9 and that is the first point in
which each guest will really be falling
asleep there's a lot of clouds in here
look at all these lights
this looks like what it would be if I
was dreaming we tend to forget about our
dream so it's kind of like reliving it
it's a very surreal feeling you don't
really see anything like this outside of
this space
I do actually feel a little bit sleepy
which i think is kind of the point I
think the feeling it gives you it's very
much like how I remember feeling from my
dream I'm feeling great I have my head
in the clouds
literally soon as you're asleep you
enter a fog bubble machine and that's
really our first transition into this
dream world
holy moly this is blowing my mind I
thought there were bubbles but they
dissolve into smoke you know in dreams
things don't really make sense this is
like that bubbles that turn into smoke
that's so bizarre
I feel like wish my bed in my dreams
from there you walk into a
black-and-white room because some people
only dream in black and white scary
looking
I've never dreamed in black and white
but if I did this would probably be a
nightmare throw me
[Music]
and then the black and white room starts
to transition black and white tiles into
a neon lit laundromat I'm making cotton
candy out of it washed a [ __ ] better
than any con can you've ever tasted out
of a washing machine in the laundromat
you can crawl through dryers into an
infinity room check this out there's a
lot of little lights in here I feel like
I'm in like a mini galaxy really serene
quiet
well that was trippy and just came out
of a washing machine moving on from
there you'll find yourself diving
underwater into a ball pit swimming pool
that looks like you're at the bottom of
a swimming pool steps to the pool I am
in a sea of plastic balls
I love the watery wavy patterns on the
ceiling we're just chillin underwater I
never want to get up from there that
transition is a 40-foot long rainbow
Hall we are in the Rainbow Room you can
see the colors changing is trippy I feel
like Alice and Alice in Wonderland going
down the rabbit hole now I find a pot of
gold at the end of the rainbow I wonder
you then find yourself immersed in our
print Gardens room filled with 70 plants
of all different prints pattern I feel
like I'm at a fancy a rainforest these
plants have little shapes on it a polka
dot leaf
there's striped leaves and then there's
mac-and-cheese leaves it could be
whatever you want it's your dream and
then it's time to wake up you'll find
yourself immersed in 15 feet of metallic
streamers we're going in
[Music]
it's never going to end I feel like I've
been here for forever
oh and we're out
it was all agree I feel like I'm waking
up now that we finished the entire tour
I finally know what the dream machine is
it was actually pretty cool there were
so many rooms that I honestly felt like
I was in my dream so after all of that
back to reality it is icy nevermind bye
guys
[Music]